COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY. IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHER INCIDENT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING. REMOTELY
OUR MEMBERS ATTENDING REMOTELY
ARE SENATOR BECKER IS GENDER
BECKER ON THE LINE. THERE IS.
AND THEN WE HAVE SENATOR DOLLY I
SEE CENTRE DOLLY AND SENATOR MEN
SENATORS MY ONLY INSTRUCTIONS TO
YOU OR IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. OR
ASK ANY QUESTIONS- PLEASE USE
YOUR RAISE A HAND OPTION IN THE
COMPUTER PROGRAM. AND ALSO A
REMINDER SENATORS ONLINE
REMEMBER TO MUTE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS. THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
USED TO REST YOUR HEAD FEATURE
THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ADMIT PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. OUR OUR IT PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU ARE DONE. THOSE ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU COULD BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. BUT TO ALLOW FOR THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE THAT MANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC INTO THE
HEARING ROOM. AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT- SOCIAL DISTANCING.
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND ALSO
WE'RE USING A TELEP
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPATE PATIENT
NUMBER. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 877-336-4437 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE TWO ZERO SIX
SIX SEVEN FOUR AGAIN THAT NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. THREE
THREE SIX. FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE TWO
ZERO. SIX SIX SEVEN FOUR FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELEPHONE CONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
AND OR TO OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATE
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE ZERO. FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. PRESS IS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER THIS COULD BE A
SHORT WAIT SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT. IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTED YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON END PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. THAT AGAIN WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION I
WILL MAINTAIN AT THE CURRENT
DURING THE HEARING. AS IS
CUSTOMARY. ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED. FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS. MUTED
OKAY I THINK WE'RE READY TO
BEGIN NOW WITH THE HEARING. WE
HAVE ONE BILL ON TODAY'S AGENDA
BEFORE WE HEAR THE
PRESENTATIONAL ABILITY ESTABLISH
A QUORUM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. J. WESSEL HERE WESSEL
HERE. DOLLY DELHI HERE. DOLLY
HERE BECKER. GREER BAKER HERE.
GORGEOUS PORGES PRESENCE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD HERE DOT. DOT
HERE AIKMAN. EIGHT MEN HERE.
GONZALEZ GROSS. GROVE HERE
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HERE. MY
CHOIR. MCGUIRE HERE. MAN. MAN
HERE MEN HERE. RUBIO RUBIO
PRESENCE STERN. STERN HERE JERRY
HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE WILL- WE WILL BEGIN NOW
COURT HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED LET'S
NOW HEAR FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR
WELCOME SENATOR WIENER- HE IS
PRESENTING AN S. V. THREE SEVEN
NINE. BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY- I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN-
I'M CALLING FOR LATER FIRST-
THANK- THE COMMITTEE AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON AMENDMENTS GIVEN THE TIGHT
TIMELINE FOR JANUARY SESSION.
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THEM
AMENDMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS BOTH
FROM THE ENERGY COMMITTEE AND
ALSO THE AMENDMENTS WE WORKED
OUT WITH THE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE BUT
LOGISTICALLY WERE UNABLE TO TAKE
AS PART OF A COMMITTEE HEARING
LAST WEEK SO EXCEPT ALL THOSE
MOMENTS FROM BOTH COMMITTEES.
ADDITIONALLY THESE AMENDMENTS
WILL INCLUDE CHANGES- THAT WE
WORKED OUT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OFFICIALS CALVO-
SPECIFYING THAT- MORE MAKING
EXTRA CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT THIS
ONLY APPLIES TO RESIDENTIAL
SOLAR PROJECTS WHICH IS ALWAYS
THE INTENT OF THE BILL. AND ALSO
EXEMPTING CITIES. WITH A
POPULATION UNDER FIVE THOUSAND.
PAUL AS YOU'LL HEAR IN THE
CUSTOMER TODAY. ARE THESE
CHANGES HAVE BROUGHT- CALVO AND
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES- AS WE
UNDERSTAND THAT TO A NEUTRAL.
POSITION ON MEETING THAT AS FAR
AS WE KNOW THIS BILL CURRENTLY
HAS NO OPPOSITION- SO SP THREE
SEVENTY NINE. REQUIRES
JURISDICTIONS OF A CERTAIN SIZE
TO IMPLEMENT ONLINE AUTOMATED
ONLINE SOLAR PERMITTING
PROCESSES FOR SIMPLE RESIDENTIAL
ROOFTOP SOLAR AND SOLAR PLUS
STORAGE SYSTEMS AND THIS ONLY
APPLIES TO RESIDENTIAL AND IT
ONLY APPLIES TO SIMPLE SYSTEMS
ANY KIND OF COMPLEX LARGER
SYSTEMS ARE NOT COVERED BY THIS
BILL ANY COMMERCIAL- SOLAR SOLAR
STORAGE IS NOT COVERED. BY THIS
BILL- TO ACCOMMODATE THIS
REQUIREMENT FOR CITIES LAST YEAR
WE PLACED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE BUDGET- FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
GRANTS TO CITIES- FOR THE MODEST
COSTS BUT THEY MAY ENCOURAGE
IMPLEMENTING AUTOMATED SOLAR
PERMITTING- THIS AUTOMATED SORE
PERMITTING IS ONE OF THE MAIN
METHODS FOR AVOIDING
UNNECESSARY. DELAYS SAVING
FINANCIAL AND STAFF RESOURCES
AND INCREASING THROUGHPUT OF
PERMITS. CURRENTLY SOLAR
PERMITTING PROCESS THESE ARE ALL
TOO OFTEN INEFFICIENT. THANK YOU
INCREASE OFF COSTS BY THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF APPLICANTS THAT FRANKLY DROP
OUT OF THE PROCESS BEFORE
INSTALLATION. AND DETER
POTENTIAL CUSTOMERS FROM
ENGAGING IN A DRAWN OUT PROCESS
TO GET TO OBTAIN A RESIDENTIAL
SOLAR SYSTEM. AUTOMATED ONLINE
SOLAR PERMITTING ALLOWS FOR A
SIMPLIFIED AND FAR MORE
EFFICIENT SOLUTION BY ALLOWING
APPLICANTS. TO APPLY AND
IMMEDIATELY RECEIVE A
TERMINATION IF THEIR PROPOSED
SYSTEM IS CODE COMPLIANT. OUR
CURRENT AUTOMATED PERMITTING
SYSTEMS ARE CAPABLE OF HANDLING
FOURTEEN TIMES MORE PERMITS.
THAN TRADITIONAL- PERMIT METHODS
. SAN JOSE WHICH RECENTLY AN
AUTOMATED SYSTEM SO IT'S 6100%
INCREASE IN PERMITS THIS
INCREASED VOLUME OF PERMITS IS
NOT A BURDEN ON BUILDING
DEPARTMENT STAFF HOWEVER. AS THE
SYSTEMS ALLOW FOR SOLAR PERMITS-
TO BE MANAGED AUTOMATICALLY-
FURTHERMORE DEPARTMENTS WILL SEE
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN FEE
COLLECTION. BECAUSE OF THE
INCREASED PERMIT ACTIVITY-
ALTHOUGH SP THREE SEVENTY NINE
DOES NOT MANDATE A SPECIFIC
TECHNOLOGY OR SYSTEMS. OF THE
BILL'S INTENT IS DIRECTLY TIED
TO SOLAR OUT PLUS A RECENTLY
DEVELOPED SOFTWARE SYSTEM FROM
THE NATIONAL RENEWABLE ENERGY
LOTS OF THE US DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY. CREATED WITH STRONG
EMPLOYER PARTICIPATION BY
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
BUILDING APARTMENTS SAFETY
EXPERTS. SOLAR INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS AND SO FORTH. SO
THERE ARE PLACES FREE AND OPEN
SOURCE AND CAN BE EASILY
IMPLEMENTED BY ANY JURISDICTION.
BUILDING APARTMENTS WILL BE ABLE
TO ON BOARD THE SYSTEM WITH ONLY
AN EMAIL ADDRESS REQUIRED. AND
EVEN MERGE THE PROGRAM WITH
OTHER COMMONLY UTILIZED
GOVERNMENT SOFTWARE IN ADDITION
THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY- IS
COMMITTED TO THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF SOLAR PLUS-
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS HAS
BEEN APPROPRIATED ALREADY. TO
SUPPORT THE SOFTWARE OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS- SOLAR UP PLUS
SPECIFICATIONS ARE BASED ON
MODEL BUILDING AN ELECTRICAL
FIRE CODES. UNDER CROSS
REFERENCE WITH THE LEADING
PERMITTING GUIDEBOOKS IN
CALIFORNIA MORE THAN FIFTY
JURISDICTIONS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
IN THE PROCESS OF EVALUATING THE
SOFTWARE. AND CITIES- SUCH AS
MODESTO MENIFEE OCEANSIDE IN
PLEASANT HILL- VARIOUS STAGES OF
ADOPTION NONE OF WHICH HAS
COMMITTED AN ISSUE. IN ADDITION
SAN JOSE. LOS ANGELES AND OTHER
CITIES HAVE ALREADY ADOPTED
SOLAR UP CLOSE- MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE B. THREE SEVENTY
NINE AS A CLIMATE BILL- AND WILL
HELP US GET TO OUR GOAL. OF A
100% CLEAN ENERGY CURRENTLY ONLY
10% OF REPAIRS OF SOLAR ENERGY.
THAT NUMBER NEEDS TO TRIPLE IN
THE NEXT DECADE IF WE EXPECT TO
MEET CLEAN ENERGY GOALS. OTHERS
WILL ALSO INCREASE RESILIENCY
DURING WILDFIRES AND OTHER
DISASTERS- COLLEAGUES- THIS IS A
BILL WHOSE TIME HAS COME. I
RESPECT LAST YEAR I WROTE. TODAY
WITH ME TO TESTIFY OR NOT TO
SETTLE WITH SUSAN G. FOR POLICY
AS PER ONE OF OUR- SPONSORS OF
THE BILL AND LARGELY IN THE
STATE DIRECTOR AT ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA. OR OTHER CO SPONSORS
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU. WE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE ORGANIZED
PRESENTATIONS DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS THE CHAIR
WHICH IS MYSELF MY INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITED TESTIMONY EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT
OF TIME- IN THIS CASE WE HAVE
TWO MINUTES OF FURTHER PROS IN
TWO MINUTES FOR THE CONS WE HAVE
A NECK JUST SUFFER WHICH- THAT
HAS ONE MINUTE LED BY LAURA THE
HAND IS THAT CORRECT- MR SENATOR
. OKAY SO WE COULD BEGIN WITH
HIS NECK ON THE LINE. I HEARD A
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY SO
WHAT WAS THE WITH MR WE'LL START
WITH MR- JUST SURF WITCHES DID I
GET THAT CORRECT A ONE MINUTE.
YES THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS
NIKOS UP WHICH I'M A OF POLICY
EXPERTS ARE A HUNDRED YEAR OLD
THINK TANK IN THE BAY AREA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO- THE
CHAIRING COMMITTEE STOPPED TO
WALK THE BUS SO PRODUCTIVELY
OFTEN FAIL. I'M SORRY THE CO
SPONSORING AT B. THREE SEVENTY
NINE CONFINEMENT CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE WORK TO DO
TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE CRISIS
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
ACCELERATE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
SOLAR NOT STATE. YOU CAN MAKE IT
QUICKER AND CHEAPER TO INSTALL
SIMPLE RESIDENTIAL ROOFTOP SOLAR
SYSTEMS DESPITE POSSIBLY JUST
LATER PERFORMANCES DON'T COST
TOO MUCH AND TAKES TOO LONG TO
CUT MADE IT SIMPLE RESIDENTIAL
ROOFTOP SOLAR SYSTEM COSTING THE
TYPICAL. CUSTOMIZABLE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THE SOLUTION IS TO ON
THIS. OF TALKING TO DURING THE
SYMBOLS. ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AUTOMATED THE PERMITTING THE
RESIDENTIAL ROOFTOP SOLAR
SYSTEMS THE CITY'S APPROVAL
PUNDITS POLITICAL PUNDITRY
REVENUE AND INSTALLED MOST MOST
ALERT AS A RESULT. S. B. THREE
SEVENTY NINE DIRECT CITIES AND
COUNTIES OVER CERTAIN POPULATION
THRESHOLDS. INCREMENTAL TO MAKE
THE PERMITTING PERSONAL
RESIDENTIAL. ROOFTOP SOLAR
SYSTEMS. IMPORTANTLY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS I WOULD NEEDED
EMAIL TO SIGN UP TO USE THE CELL
LAPTOP PLUS SYSTEM WHICH IS FREE
SOFTWARE DEVELOPED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
WILL ALSO HAVE A TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR GRANT PROGRAMS WILL BE
FUNDED OUT OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
TO COMPENSATE JURISDICTIONS AT
ANY COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DOCTOR WILL TO MAKE. THIS BILL
IS NOT AN UNFUNDED MANDATE. WITH
SP THREE SEVENTY NINE CALIFORNIA
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
MAJOR STRIDES TO POWERING UP
STATE WITH A 100% CLEAN ENERGY
AT NO ADDITIONAL COST. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TO APPROACH
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU AND I
WILL GO TO LAURA D. HAN. ONE
MINUTE. THANK YOU CAROUSEL AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'VE ALREADY
HAD STATE DIRECTOR WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AT WE'RE
THRILLED TO BE WORKING WITH
BIRDS AND INTERVENER. THE
THUNDER XBT SEVENTY NINE DOLLAR
ACCESS BACK. CALIFORNIA ONE OF
THE FUNNIEST PLACES IN THE WORLD
AND WE'VE LED THE WAY WITH
ROOFTOP SOLAR GROWTH SH AND
RIPPED UP THE CARPET NO AIR
POLLUTION IT CAUSES NO SALES IN
OUR BEAUTIFUL COASTLINE. AND
THERE'S NO NEW LAND LEAD IT.
NEEDED WHICH IS WHY POLL AFTER
POLL SHOWS THAT. THE TOP BILLER
IN THE MOST POPULAR KIND OF
ENERGY AND IN THE STATE- BUT OUR
POTENTIAL TO EXPAND ROOFTOP
SOLAR IT'S REALLY ENORMOUS- WE
COULD MEET THREE QUARTERS OF OUR
EIGHT OUT I THINK YOU NEED. JUST
BY CATCHING THE SIGN ON EXISTING
ROOFTOP ACCORDING. TO THE
NATIONAL RENEWABLE ENERGY LAB.
THANK YOU PROCESS. FILLER PERMIT
HAS OVER BURDEN LOCAL. WITH OUR
OF P. WORK. AND BECAUSE- THE
LATE INTO SELECT ON THEIR ROOF.
WHICH WHY OUR DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
DEVELOP SOLAR AT AND- WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED TO- HE HAS
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD THE WAY IN
ADOPTING THIS TECHNOLOGY ACROSS
THE STATE. I'M REALLY FEED THE
FELON HIGHLIGHTING THAT TOPS IN
INSURING- THAT ANYTHING CAN YOU
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT AND AFFORD
MORE CALIFORNIA BUT CAN YOU
CATCH THAT ON CAMERA SH THIRTY
LIKELY ASK FOR AN IDOL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL GO TO ANY
SPEAKERS AND PORT HERE. IN THE.
GALLERY WE DON'T SEE ANYONE. SO
WE'LL GO. THE MODERATOR IN ASKED
THE MODERATOR Q. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. OF S. B. THREE SEVENTY
NINE. THANK YOU MR CHAIR IF HE
WISHES COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST MY
NUMBER IS NINE FIFTEEN. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA SO LEAST
SHOP ON BEHALF OF SUNPOWER IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE
NEXT SPEAKER OUR NEXT MY NUMBER
IS. NINE SEVENTY NINE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIRTY NINE FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT AND I'VE
ALSO BEEN ASKED TO CONVEY THAT
THE COURT- THAT SIERRA CLUB WHO
IS- BACK IN ANOTHER HEARING
RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AT NINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEWS
SURE MEMBERS LAPTOP AND GINA
COMPANY BY THURSDAY- HERE ON-
THINK WORK FOR THE CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY AND THAT
SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION BOTTOM PART THANK
THAT THE APPROPRIATE FOR. NEXT
PICKER TEN NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS THIS IS THE ONLY
CATHOLIC WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT PICKER.
NINE TWENTY NINE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS JEFF ARE
REPRESENTING SUPPORT TECHNOLOGY
CALLING AT THE PORT OF SPEECH
RECENTLY NINE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE CENTRE FREEING FOR.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. NINE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR NUMBERS THIS IS DAN CURRY
CARAMEL APPLE PALMETTO SOLAR AND
STRONG SUPPORTER THAT THE THREE
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. NEXT
BECAUSE. NINE TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THIS IS CATHERINE WITH CONSTANT
REPRESENTING THE NUMBER ENERGY
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU. NEXT
BIGGER. NINE NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS GERRY
GRUBER FOUNDER OF SUNLIGHT IN
POWER IN BERKELEY. AND I AM
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT BEST
BE SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU. OKAY
NEXT PICKER. NINE TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MONA TIERNEY
LLOYD WITH AND NOW NORTH AMERICA
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY
NINE. OKAY THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
. NINE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU.
AFTER THIS IS OUR RICH
REPRESENTING A SCARCE OVER
INTERNATIONAL CORPORATION IN
CARMICHAEL CALLING STRONG
SUPPORT AGAINST THE THREE SEVEN
NINE THANK YOU. NEXT BIGGER.
NINE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME ANYWAY
REPRESENTING OF OCTOBER CALLING
AND DRUNK THE PARK AND I THREE
THREE SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOUR NEXT PICKER. NINE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE NUMBERS WITH THE PAKISTAN
SAYS REPRESENTING KAPLAN CALLING
IN FOR. THE NIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. NINE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
BEN DAVIS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION
AND CALLING IN SUPPORT THANKS.
NINE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ROGER DICKINSON OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY
NINETY MOVEMENT PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME OKAY VERY WELL WE'RE
GONNA MOVE. TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION NOW WE HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITION. PRESENTATION BY
BRADY BRADY. BURDEN OR GARDEN-
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING A
CITY OFFICIALS IS HE ON THE LINE. HEY GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ABOUT
THREE SEVEN NINE WITH ANOTHER
WINNER I JUST WANTED TO REMIND
YOU. IF I CAN JUST AN INTERRUPT
YOU I JUST WANT TO REMIND YOU
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU- AGAIN MY
NAME IS BRADY GARDEN ON THE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR THE
COMPANY BUILDING OFFICIALS I
WANTED TO BEGIN BY THANKING
SENATOR WIENER AND HIS STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THE THREE SEVEN
NINE I WILL HAD BEEN FOLLOWING
THE BILL CLOSELY FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND THE FEATURES
DOUBLING UP IN THE MOUNTAINS AND
SENATOR TO ENGAGE WITH US ON HIS
WELL CURRENTLY HELLO HOW THEY
POSITION OF OPPOSING WITH UNITED
ON THE BILLING OF CURRENT FORM.
KABUL HAS WORKED FOR DECADES-
PRUDENT AND ENFORCEABLE
LEGISLATION HELP MEET THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA LAUDABLE GOALS
ROLLED INTO CLIMATE CHANGE IN
MENTAL STATE LEGISLATORS AND
THEIR EFFORTS TO BRIDGE THE
DIGITAL WITHOUT SENDING BILLS
MUST BE PURSUED THE PLANE
CONSTRUCTIVELY WINTER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ABILITY TO COMBINE
IMPORTANT ALL THE PERSON
FOREMOST TRAVEL EXPOUNDED UPON
THE PRINCIPLE THAT LOCAL
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENTS MUST HAVE
THE ABILITY TO MAKE CHANGES IN
EMPLOYMENT. PROGRAMS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. C. MOBILE A LARGER
CITY MAY NOT BE. AS NEEDED FOR.
SMALLER TO THE LOCKER ROOM READ.
UNDER TECHNICOLOR CLOSE WITH
TECH. DOES NOT BEEN. BUT AND-
FREE SPEECH YOU CAN. REGARDING
BORDER. WE QUALIFY HOUSEHOLD A
DOCTOR THE SOLAR OUT PLUS I MEAN
THE FIGHTERS CHECKS AND- I'VE
BEGUN PILOTING A NEW TECHNOLOGY
AND RESPECT AND CARE THEY CAN.
COME TO BELIEVE THAT THE MONEY
PROVIDED IN THE BUDGET
APPROPRIATION SHOULD BE USED. AS
A PILOT PROJECT TO PROPERLY TEST
AND PROVIDE FEEDBACK AND ARE YOU
ELEMENT AND NO ONE CAN AFFORD
IT. AND THEY DID HERS A BUILDING
OFFICIAL PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY IS. THE MOST
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF OUR JOB. YOU
MENTIONED- NO DOES NOW THAT THE
PRIVATE GLOBAL ENERGY THAT. WE
REALLY HAVE. THAT AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE THE LANGUAGE ABOUT THAT
I'M FINE- WILL GO SOLAR ECLIPSE
WAS NOT CAPABLE OF PERMITTING
ENERGY STORAGE SYSTEM THE
LANGUAGE BUT THE NFL ALLOWING
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
APPLICABILITY WHEN REVIEWING
APPLICATIONS. AND ONLINE
PERMITTING SYSTEM ISNOT GOOD
FOR VIEWING OF THE CRIME THE
APPLICATION. IN CLOSING I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH THEM
ABOUT PUBLIC CONCERNS ABOUT THE
THIRTY. NINE WITHOUT THAT
TROUBLE HAS AGREED TO AMENDMENTS
DRESSING UP OF OUR CONCERNS OF
THE FUNCTION THIS PHONE WILL
LOOK FORWARD TO BRINGING OUR
OPPOSITION WITHIN THEM AND- ARE
OFFICIALLY PRINTED. HELLO IS
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK UNDER
WINTER STOP WITH MANY FACTORS.
ON JUST THAT UNDER THIS BELT.
SHAKER CONSIDERATION OUR
CURRENT. I THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR GREAT WORK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW- TO- SPEAK SET
UP. ANYBODY HERE IN THE GALLERY
WISH TO SPEAK NO ONE HERE. AND-
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINES NOW
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF TWO SP THREE SEVEN
NINE. THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION THAT'S THE THREE
SEVENTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN THERE. MY FIRST COMMENT
COMES FROM NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS THERE
GOLFING BAFFLING TO CALIFORNIA
CITIES WE DO NOT HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THE BILLBOARD ONE
HUNDRED LEADER AND HIS STAFF ON
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND SPONSORS
FOR ADDRESSING MANY OF OUR
CONCERNS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE BILL. A NEW AMENDMENT WHEN
THEY GOING TO PRINT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND AGAIN I WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THE SPEAKERS CHOOSE. A
STATE THEIR NAME AND THE
POSITION. ON THE BILL AND IF
THEY'RE REPRESENTING AND ANYBODY
IN PARTICULAR. MODERATOR PLEASE-
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE SEVENTY
NINE OKAY VERY WELL AND- THE
AUTHOR ALREADY STATED IN HIS
OPENING PRESENTATIONS TAKING
AMENDMENTS JUST WANTED TO. I GET
THE- HE'S- NODDING HIS HEAD IN
AGREEMENT- WITH AMENDMENTS TO WE
HAVE ANYONE ON THE- OF THE
COMMITTEE LIKE TO SPEAK. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
. AS THE- AUTHOR SAID. THIS IS A
CLIMATE BILL. AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT I MOVE THE BILL. BUT IT'S
MORE THAN THAT IT'S MUCH MORE
THAN THAT. IT IS WE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE STEP BACK AND TRY TO
DEAL WITH MANY OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE FACE. THE FRUSTRATION
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS IN DEALING
WITH GOVERNMENT AND A SLOW AND
DIFFICULT IT IS WHETHER IT'S
BUILDING HOW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OR WHATEVER ELSE IT MAY BE. WHAT
THIS NATION DOES IT'S IMPORTANT
LESSON TO ALL OF US. HERE IT IS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WORKING
IN COORDINATION WITH US TO
CREATE THE DEATH ROW THE
NATIONAL RENEWABLE ENERGY LABS.
THAT CREATE A PLAN THAT
AUTOMATES PLAN REVIEW PROMOTES
A- CODE COMPLIANT APPROVALS AND
ISSUES PERMITS. FOR SOLAR ENERGY
SYSTEM ENERGY STORAGE SYSTEMS.
IT WAS SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS.
THAT IS ONE SMALL STEP FOR
GOVERNMENT FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND NOW WITH SENATOR WIENER'S
MEASURE STATE GOVERNMENT WORKING
TOGETHER WE SAUCE PRESIDENT
CLINTON DO THIS ON MARCH FOURTH
TWO THOUSAND WHEN HE GAVE ACCESS
TO THE SATELLITES THAT THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES WERE USING
THAT WE NOW HAVE WITH ALL OF OUR
PHONES SO WE CAN USE OUR GPS
SYSTEMS. AND SO I SHARE THIS.
BILL FOR US THAT APPEARS TO BE A
SMALL STATEMENT IN A VERY BIG
ISSUE ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE THAT
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE UNIFORMS
A LEVEL OF THINKING THAT WE
SHOULD ALL ENGAGE IN. IN TERMS
OF FINDING PLACES WHERE
GOVERNMENT AT EVERY LEVEL
CONGLOMERATE AND WE CAN DEAL
WITH SOME OF THESE FUNDAMENTAL
FRUSTRATIONS AND FUNDAMENTAL
PUBLIC POLICY PROBLEMS THAT WE
DEAL WITH SO AGAIN I STAND IN
SUPPORT AND APPLAUD THE- AUTHOR
FOR HIS. EFFORT IN THIS REGARD
AND HOPE THAT THIS IS JUST ONE
SMALL STEP FOR US IN GOVERNMENT
AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR US TO HAVE APPROVALS
ON IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY
AREAS. LIKE HAVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AMONG OTHER AREAS THANK
YOU. ONE SMALL STEP FOR
GOVERNMENT AND ONE LARGE STEP
FOR MANKIND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
VERY ELOQUENT WORDS- WHAT ELSE-
CENTER GROVE. WELLS ANYONE ELSE
VACANCY HAND. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR. QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU S. THANK YOU SENATOR I
DO UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO GO I THINK IT WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL IF- THESE PROJECTS
WERE APPROVED FASTER BUT I DO
HAVE A CONCERNS WITHIN THE
DISTRICT AND- JUST OUTSIDE OF MY
DISTRICT IN THE NORTHERN AREA.
FOR INSTANCE- ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WAS ASKED WITH
FRESNO WITH ONE OF PERMITS
ISSUED ONLINE THERE'S NO WAY TO
VERIFY THE STRUCTURE IS FULLY.
PERMITTED WHERE THE SOLAR WILL
BE INSTALLED. THIS COULD CAUSE A
PROBLEM- WHEN A FINAL INSPECTION
AS REQUESTED. SO WHEN ANY PERMIT
IS ISSUED IN FRESNO THE PLANNING
STAFF REVIEWS A SITE PLAN AND
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NO
OUTSTANDING ISSUES ON THE
PROPERTY. PRISON WAS ALSO NOT
DIGITIZED THE RECORDS OF
RESEARCH CAN TAKE SOME TIME-
WE'LL LOCALS AND LOCAL AUTHORITY
OR THE HAVE THE FINAL
PERMITTING. PROCESS IN THIS
LEGISLATION YES SIR- THROUGH THE
CHAIR. ON A COUPLE THINGS FIRST
OF ALL WHEN SOMEONE FIRST OF
THIS BILL. DOES NOT IN ANYWAY
TAKE AWAY CITIES ABILITY TO
CONDUCT A PHYSICAL INSPECTION.
SURVEY IF THERE'S SOME SORT OF
SAFETY ISSUE- SOME SORT OF
STRUCTURAL ISSUE THAT'LL COME
OUT AN INSPECTION AND THEY
DISPOSED NOT TAKE AWAY THEIR
ABILITY TO DO THAT. IN ADDITION
AND THE PERSON THE AUTOMATED
PERMITTING PROCESS. THEY HAVE TO
ANSWER THE CONTRACTOR WHOEVER IS
INSTALLING. HAS THE ANSWER I
BELIVE IT'S A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE QUESTIONS TO ENSURE.
FULL COMPLIANCE AND SO A LOT OF
ISSUES FOR WELL IT THERE ARE
TWENTY FIVE QUESTIONS. AND THEN
OF COURSE THEY CAN STILL DO A
PHYSICAL INSPECTION THEY'RE VERY
ORIGINAL VERSION OF THE BILL- WE
CHANGED THE PHYSICAL INSPECTION.
TO A VIRTUAL INSPECTION THAT
CAUSED SOME. CONSTERNATION AND
SO WE REMOVE THAT PART BILL
PREVIOUSLY- SO THAT. THE THAT'S
I CAN RESP- TO THE THANK YOU AND
AN WORK. AT IT MY UNDERSTANDING
IT I AM ALL THE THIS IS WAS RE
FROM THIS BUT YET WAS UP. TO
STILL BY COW BUILDING IF. CAN
GO- YES THE CAL. BILL INTO. SO
DAY. S. TOMB. AND EXCHANGE WOULD
DROP THEIR PERSON. WE TAKE BOTH
AMENDMENTS AND YOU KNOW. WERE
ACCEPTING. AND OUR UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT CORRECT AWESOME IS THERE
DROPPING THEIR OPPOSITION. I
WILL I WILL JUST SORT OF SAY.
THAT TESTIMONY WAS A LITTLE BIT
. CONVOLUTED AND AT THE VERY END
I BELIEVE HE AID THAT HE'S
DROPPING HIS OPPOSITION ALTHOUGH
IT WAS. IT WAS GARBLED BUT ONCE
IT GOES INTO PRINT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS. THAT THEY WILL
DROP THEIR OPPOSITION AND THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES IS ALSO AS I
UNDERSTAND IT GOING TO DROP ITS
OPPOSITION. ONCE THE AMENDMENTS
ARE IN PRINT. THANK YOU SIR.
WE'LL GO TO SENATOR BECKER.
THANKS YEAH HI THIS IS MRS YOU
KNOW FIFTEEN YEARS OR SO AGO WE
STARTED REALLY RAMP UP SOLAR IN
THE STATE WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
MAKE THE WHOLE PROCESS OF.
VIEWED BACK TO BUY A SATELLITE-
BUT DIDN'T PRESENT SAY HE GETS
STOLEN EVERYTHING LEADING UP TO
ACTUALLY SENDING A TRUCK OUT
THERE AND GET AND COMPLETE THE
INSTALLATION TRY TO MAKE ALL
THAT AS EFFICIENT AND
INEXPENSIVE AS POSSIBLE. AND
THAT'S WHY I'M SO SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BILL I THINK IT REALLY HELP
IN THAT EFFORT I REPLIED NOT THE
AUTHOR AS WELL AS A SPUR AND
SPONSORS AND- I JUST THINK YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO DRAMATICALLY
RAMP UP SOLAR IN THIS STATE AND
THIS WILL HELP GET US THERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHAT ELSE.
DO AND THE DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR DODD
. THE SEARCH FOR IT ALSO. WELL
YOU CAN MAKE MOTIONS DURING A
SPEECH. SIR WE- DO YOU WANT TO
WRAP UP YOUR COMMENTS. CLOSER
VEHICLE CLOSING COMMENTS WITH
EMOTIONAL AND REGIONAL CHAIRMAN
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIVE-
THANK YOU BECAUSE- CLARK PLEASE
CALL THE. S. B. THREE SEVENTY
NINE BY SENATOR WIENER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL BY WESSEL
HI. DOLLY LA SP THREE SEVEN NINE
WINNER NO. DALI KNOWN BACKER. B.
THREE SEVEN NINE WE ARE YES
BECKER YES. GORGEOUS. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI DOT. DODD I. EIGHT
MEN. EIGHT MEN I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I. GROSS. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG I REQUIRE. MCGUIRE I
MAN MAN SP THREE SEVENTY NINE
WEINER EYED MAN I. RUBIO RUBIO I
STERN- STERN I. TERRY HAVE
ELEVEN DAYS AND ONE NOW OKAY SO
THE BILL IS OFFICIALLY OUT AND
THAT BRINGS US TO THE LAST ITEM
ON OUR CALENDAR SO DO WE HAVE
ANY MEMBERS THAT ARE OUTSTANDING
. ANY VOTE SENTIMENT OKAY
EVERYBODY'S VOTED. OKAY THE NINE
. THE BILL IS OUT. WITHOUT BRING
JUST THE END OF OUR COMMITTEE.
AND SP THREE SEVEN NINE IS OUCH. I JUST WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TEST FOR TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US ONLY ONE INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORDS THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WITH
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS IS ADJOURNED.